Tom Brady crossing the end zone and not
looking back y'all for real this time
Tom dropping the bombshell retirement
news just 12 hours after hitting the 80
for Brady red carpet
thank you guys for allowing me to live
my absolute dream
thing with his voice
cracking in that 52 sec post it's a
it's a game over for Tom but the news
looks like a win for his bank account
his total earnings over 23 years in the
NFL 333 million but he will make 375
million in just 10 years working as an
analyst for Fox Sports I really thank
you guys so much for supporting me my
family Tom's ex Gisele Bundchen
commented saying wishing you only
wonderful things in this new chapter of
your life and looks like she's getting
back to work Giselle was spotted at a
photo shoot last week amidst rumors that
she will tell all in an expose for
Vanity Fair
what's next for Tom he says he wants to
be a present father for his three kids
and of course there's Hollywood Are You
Gonna Act again because let's see I
don't know make some offers let's see
what we can do all right football movies
the booth what's next we're all trying
to figure it out so just taking it day
by day and my friend says the future
happens a day at a time so that's what
life's all about
Tom looked at ease celebrating the film
out Friday alongside Rita Moreno Sally
Field Lily Tomlin and Jane Fonda in
between tapes how much fun did you have
with those ladies so much oh my God I
learned so much just watching they're so
authentic they know they make it look so
easy
whoever gets Star Struck anymore I am
Starstruck with with athletes if any of
the Dodgers came on right now I think
I'd have to go home Justin Turner is
here I saw him he's here who's here
Justin Turner is here okay now I'm
nervous
folks this is my grandson his name is
Justin Fisher you've got a big exciting
project coming up fast X is this a crazy
time of my life or what I will be honest
it was my idea to get her in Fast and
Furious 10. does he get a cut an agent
yeah why not okay
this movie is a bit of a nine to five
reunion what would it take to get you
all together again we haven't been able
to get a script that we were satisfied
with if you don't have the script you
can't start and we're trying to make it
happen uh before one of us checks out
[Music]
foreign